الاخطاء التحكيميه جزء من اللعبه ومتحد
كره القدم هكذا يقول البعض لكن يقولون ذلك
عندما يفوز الفريق الذي يشجعونه لكن عندما
تحدث اخطاء في الجانب الاخر لا تصبح
الاخطاء متعبل شبه جريمه دوليه هناك في
الواقع الكثير من الجدل على مستوى التحكيم
والاخطاء منذ بدايه كاس العالم لكن الدور
ربع النهائي شهد حاله قياسيه من التذمر
وشكوى واللاعبين والمدربين
هولندا
18 بطاقه صفراء في اجواء مشحونه داخل
وخارج الملعب الغريب ان اللاعبين الفريقين
خرجوا بعد المباراه لينتقدوه علنا في
البرتغال يتعجب اللاعبون من تعيين حكم من
ارجنتيني في لقائهم امام المغرب اما
المنتخب الاسود الثلاثه فيصف الحكم
البرازيلي الذي دار لقاءهم بمنتخب فرنسا
بانه سيئ جدا المزيد
[موسيقى]
العديد من القرارات التحكيميه المثيره
للجدل في المونديال نستعرض بعضها مدرب
منتخب غانا وصف ركله جزاء التي سجلها
رونالدو في مرمى فريقه بانها هديه خاصه من
الحكم وقرار خاطئ كلف فريقه المباراه اما
لاعب منتخب اوروغواي فاحتاجه على حكم
لقائهم امام غانا لانهم اعتقدوا انه حرمهم
الركلتي الجزاء واضاع عليهم فرصه تاهل
لدور ال16 هدف اليابان المثير للجدل امام
اسبانيا اعتقد الجمهور ان الكره تجاوزت خط
المرمى في تمريره قبل الهدف لكن الحقيقه
انها لم تخرج بكامل المحيطها لفريق
اسرائيل ربما سنتيمتر واحد او اقل بعد
لقاء المغرب في ربع النهائي اتهمت في
مدافع البرتغال الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
بالمحابات الارجنتين وترتيب اللقب من اجل
ميسي بسبب تعيين حكم الارجنتيني واعترض
على ايقافته المباراه كثيرا وعدم احتسابه
وقتا بدل ضائع كافي
والابراج انتقاد ميسي لحكم مباراه هولندا
والارجنتين الذي عاتب الفيفا وقال ان
عليهم مراجعه اختياراتهم للحكام في كاس
العالم على كل حال من الدوحه سال جماهير
كاس العالم هل الاخطاء التحكيميه جزء من
متعه كره القدم
تمام تمام
الحديثه والبرمجه
الطريقه القديمه اللي كان الحكم هو يقرر
في المباراه الحكم
الحكم هو جزء من اللاعبين فهو طبيعي هو
عايش جو المباراه هو اللي يقرر لازم نوظف
التكنولوجيا في في تطوير كره القدم شلون
نوظفها مثل اللي حاصل الان في في كاس
العالم 2022 شلون نشوف التفاصيل الاوف
سايد يعني يعني يبين لك الاوفسايد خلال
الاقل من سنتي يبين لك هل هو متسلل ولا
غير متسلل هذا جزء بالنسبه لي يعني يعيد
الحق لاصحابه
الرياضه
في مونديال قطر 2020 كيف هو تقييم المستوى
وفي حال انه كان فير جدا وعادل جدا في نصف
البشر الذي يحبوه معروفه تعريف الحكم ابسط
تعريف للحكم هو الشخص الذي لن يحبه نصف
البشر وان كان عادله يعني مبدئيا هو تحت
ضغط مش طبيعي وبعدين نقطه ثانيه انا
باتكلم على التحكيم بشكل مطلق قبل ان
نتناول مونديال قطر
كم مره ثبت ان في حكام مرتين وتم ضبطهم
بشكل عملي بالادله انا تقريبا لا اتذكر
رغم عملي في هذا المجال لسنوات طويله
التحكيم في راي الشخصي وتعتبروه مجرد راي
شخصي الحكم ضحيه مدير فني لم يتمكن من وضع
التكتيك المناسب ضحيه لاعب لم يوفق في
تسجيل هدف ضحيه ميديا انا اعمل في الميديا
ومش سر انا بقوله الميديا حينما تكون ضد
الحكم فهي اكثر جاذبيه لانها تخاطب عقل
الجمهور
وعاطفه الجمهور الجمهور بطبيعته بيبحث عن
مبرر كل مبررات العالم قبل ان يقول ان
منتخب او فريقه لم يكن جيدا مين
هو الحكم فاسمحوني انا يعني واحد من الناس
متعاطف مع التحكيم والحكام لكن اذا تناول
22 بشكل محدد انا باشوف انه اجمالا جيد ما
فيش حالات تحكيميه نقدر نقول ان زياره
مسار مباريات من يقرر اذا اخطا الحكم في
تحكيمه ومن يحاسب خصوصا عندما نتحدث عن
مباريات مصريه
يعني كاس العالم تحديدا على راس لجنه
التحكيم اهم واحد خلينا نقول مش اهم واحد
من اهم الحكام في تاريخ كره القدم برلي
وجه كولينا الحكم الايطالي واعتقد انه بذل
كل اللي ما بيشتغلش مع الفيفا على فكره
انا باقول كلام في حر يعني الكولينا بذل
جهد غير عادي قبل بدايه المونديال واثناء
المونديال مساله الاعداد مساله الاختيار
بناء على الكفاءه سيمينارز سبقت كاس
العالم وتدريب في اعلى مستوياته لكي يضمن
واستخدام التقنيه ايضا يعني اكثر بطوله في
تاريخ كاس العالم كان فيها استخدام تقنيه
هي مونديال قطره 22 مساله من يحاسب هو
بالتاكيد لجنه الحكام وافضل ان يحاسبه
لجنه الحكام او جهه رسميه وبيتم باستبعاد
الحكام من غير موفقين والابقاء على الحكام
الجايين للمراحل لكن الحكم لو من جانب
الميديا والجماهير فعليه السلام
حكم مباراه الارجنتين هولندا حقق رقم
القياس قياسيا في هذا المونديال اكثر من
خمسه عشرات بطاقه صفراء في مباراه واحده
الحق عليه او على الجهاز الفني للانضباطي
تم استبعاده بس استبعدته
خلينا نتكلم بواقعيه وبصراحه انا رغم اني
من عشاق ميسي على المستوى الشخصي بعيدا
يعني عن العمل في مجال الاعلاف ميسي انتقد
الحكم فمن من من
اكثر جاذبيه للجمهور وللمونديال حكم معظم
الناس ما تعرفش اسمه ولا لا ميسي ميسي
اعتقد ميسي
كان بلغ قليلا في اتخاذ الحكم ال 18 بطاقه
صفراء فردتها ظروف المباراه السلوك
اللاعبين كان جدا سيء حتى منتخب الارجنتين
وحاله من العصبيه ما بين المنتخبين فرضت
هذا الايقاع ولكن احيانا في احنا بنقول في
سينس في قدره على اداره الامور بشكل
احترافي همم احاول بقدر الامكان امتص غضب
اللاعبين ابتسامه خفيفه احيانا واقعه
تستحق الانذار في بدايه المباراه علي ان
لا اتعجل في اعطاء بطاقات صفراء لكي لا
يتوتر الجو لاهوز من الحكام المتوترين
قليلا وهو من الحكام اللي بيعيشوا حمى
الكلاسيكو بين برشلونه وريال مدريد فهو
متعود على اجواء المتوتره ولكن توتر وكان
زياده في هذه المباراه
متوتره الى اي حد يجب ان تكون شخصيه الحكم
قويه تفرض نفسها على الحضور تفرق نفسها
على حتى اللاعبين وايضا المدربين وعامل
الفيفا
معنى قوه الشخصيه كيف يكون قوي شخصيه مع
لاعب مليون مره اكثر شهره منه مع لاعب
يتقاضى 40 مليون يورو في السنه
حكم يعني الفكره ببساطه ان تكون سوفت وفي
نفس الوقت قوي حكمه المساله تحتاج حكمه زي
فكره اداره الاب لابنائه مثلا او المدرس
في صف دراسه
مزيج من الحكمه عفوا يعني مزيج من الحكمه
والقوه في نفس الوقت
ذكيه ومتطوره
الالي الى اي ماده بالفعل يمكن القاء كل
يوم على الحكم في ظل الوجود جهاز فني لجنه
التحكم كل هذه التقنيات التي تثبت بالاجل
حقيقيه
ابدا لن تغني عن البشر ابدا ستظل هناك
نسبه ولو بسيطه نحتكم الى مساله التقدير
البشريه خاصه في الركلات الجزاء الحكم
احيانا بيعود الى الفار يشاهد اللعبه اكثر
من مره ولكنها في النهايه مساله تقديريه
بالتاكيد وجود التقنيات ساعه كثير في انه
يخفف العلبه عن الحكم في مرجعيه بيرجع لها
لان الحكم قبل الفار مثلا او التقنيات كان
يتخذ القرار في جزء ام سليم احصائيا
معلومه 245 قرار بيتخذهم متوسط القرارات
عدد القرارات اللي بيتخذ الحكم في كل
مباراه لكي ان تتخيلي ان تكوني في هذا
الموقف انت امام 245 قرار وكل قرار في
الجزء ان الثاني او اقل من الثانيه عندي
راي شخصي في مساله التقنيه
قاللت من حجم الاخطاء الاخطاء ولكنها اخذت
من بعد متعب كره القدم اذا افترضنا قاعده
اساسيه ان الحكم فير ولا يتعمد الظلم
فعلينا ان نذهب مع الحكم سيخطئ هذه المره
وفيصيب في المره القادمه المساله لما كانت
ماشيه كده كان فيها نوع من المتعه اكثر
وانا رايي لا افرده على احد يعني في ناس
كثير جدا مع فكره التقنيه يقول لك مجرد
انه يرجع للفقراء ويتخذ قرار صحيح بفضل
التقنيه ده مهم جدا ويقرر مصير المباراه
في بعض الاحيان
محمد حامد شكرا
الكلمه دي احنا فرضنا ثقافتنا على العالم
عند الانجليز مصطلح معروف من فتره كبيره
اسمه الواكس
انا
باقول لشباب منطقه
بالهويه بتاعتك هويتك شفتك تقدر تروح
للعالميه من واقع الهويه اللي انت نشات
عليها اشكركم وصباحكم جميل